Last time on True Fear I told you about my
creepy experiences with The Hobo King.
If you haven’t seen that episode, I’ll
leave a link so you can go see it.
I’ve also been talking with more people
who used to live at that building who saw
my Hobo King video, and I’ve come across
some new information and horror stories, so
if you’d like to see a Part II to that video,
leave a like and let me know in the comments.
So we basically had to flee the apartment,
as it became unlivable due to the bugs.
They were supposed to treat our apartment
right away, but they cared about money a lot
more than the well being of their tenants,
and that’s today’s horror story.
No, but when that happened we found ourselves
hotel hopping for a while.
As I mentioned in episode 2, it was student
housing, so the school would put us up in
nearby hotels.
I know this sounds cool, like some awesome
Zac and Cody stuff, but the apartment complex
manager kept lying about when they would actually
be treating our apartment, so the school kept
putting us in hotels for one day at a time.
And different hotels would fill up on different
days, so we had to move to a different hotel
almost every night, and it just got to the
point where it was exhausting.
Couple that with the fact that we were in
classes and had our own lives to deal with
and had to constantly fight with the apartment
management to get our unit fixed and the hotel
thing wasn’t a whole lot of fun.
It was also kind of a health detriment.
We didn’t have a kitchen to cook in, nor
did we have any place we could store food,
so we had to go out and get fast food all
of the time.
That’s where this story begins, at an Extended
Stay America in Woodland Hills, CA.
So I had gotten out of class and checked into
the hotel.
I was feeling pretty hungry so I decide to
go out and find somewhere I could get food.
In the hotel, there are all these super-long
hallways, and our room was at the end of the
last hallway.
So I’m headed out of there and I see this
door partially open at the end of one of the
halls, and this older woman standing in the
dark.
So I think, “Oh she must be getting ready
to go out and leave her room.”
Well, turns out I was right… in a way.
Once I get closer she walks out of the room
and she’s standing in the hallway.
It seems as if she’s looking at me, but
when I saw her eyes, it was more like she
was looking past me or looking through me
or something.
Like her head was pointed in my direction,
but it was almost like she didn’t see me
at all, she was in her own world, and in this
world of hers there was a ghost standing just
past where I was.
I know this hard to picture, but that’s
the best way I can describe it.
So that was unsettling, but not as unsettling
as what would come next.
The voice.
It was like something straight out of a horror
movie.
And what she said didn’t make it any better.
Now I don’t remember her exact words, so
I’m just paraphrasing.
It was something along the lines of “Why
hello Gerald!
Won’t you come in and have some supper;
make you some supper.”
And then... she actually started laughing.
And meanwhile I just didn’t even think about
responding to any of this.
I just kept walking and never looked back.
She kept talking as I walked away but I didn’t
hear her.
So yeah, that was one of the creepier things
I’d ever seen, but I guess it could have
been like a prank or maybe she had a bluetooth
I didn’t see or something.
I was honestly just trying to come up with
an excuse for my own comfort at that point.
But after that I went out, got some food and
came back.
And at that point I had pretty much forgotten
about it all, but then I turn into that hallway
again, and what do I see?
In the same exact spot where the woman wandered
out to before, there was a police officer
taking down some notes and the door that the
woman came out of was open and the place was
cleared out.
I never found out what happened that night
while I was out getting food, but I still
do wonder if I had just been lucky to have
not been a victim.
Clearly SOMETHING went down while I was gone
and it was big enough to get the cops called
and start an investigation.
What stuck with me more than anything was
the look in that woman’s eye.
She just looked so hollow.
After thinking more about the situation, I
came up with the theory that she was having
some kind of flashback in her head.
Possibly a trauma induced reaction.
What led me to this theory?
Well, first I wanted to analyse why she was
even staying at this hotel.
This isn’t in like a touristy part of LA.
It’s at least 30 minutes away from the beach,
30 minutes away from Universal, and 45 minutes
away from Hollywood.
So that left me with two likely possibilities:
she’s visiting family, or there’s something
wrong at home, causing her to have to stay
in the hotel -- the same reason I was technically
staying there.
Based on her behaviour, I’ve decided to
explore the latter, as that seems more likely
to me.
We have very little to go off of in this situation,
really just what she said, which, unfortunately
I don’t remember all of it perfectly word
for word.
This was before I started doing True Fear,
so I didn’t think to write it down or anything.
But I think her dialogue does offer some possible
clues as to what was going on.
So first, there was this character Gerald
who she seemed to be talking to.
Based on the way that she was talking to him
and the fact that she asked him to come in
for supper, Gerald may have been her husband,
or possibly a her son.
At the beginning of the interaction, she seems
kind of surprised to see Gerald, so I took
this as they had been apart for some time
and she was now day dreaming or hallucinating
about seeing him again.
That’s why I think that this may have been
trauma related in some way.
For example, if Gerald was her husband, I
get the sense that he hurt her and abandoned
her in some way, causing her to fall into
a deep depression and replay the idea she
has in her head of when they would see each
other again.
This idea is supported by the fact that she
starts laughing.
That leads me to believe that in her head,
Gerald responded to her and said something
that she found funny.
This would also kind of explain why she was
waiting in the hotel room and came out when
she saw me.
It wouldn’t be so different from when you
see a dog waiting by the window for their
master to return.
If she truly did have some kind of traumatic
experience with Gerald, it’s possible that
this was just her way of dealing with.
I’m no expert on the human brain, but if
we do go with the story about the woman and
Gerald…
I shudder to think about what may have caused
her to get kicked out of the hotel and the
cops called.
I really have nothing to go on here, but my
gut tells me that her perceived reunion with
Gerald may not have gone that well and possibly
brought up some repressed scars.
Again, I have no actual idea what went down,
but I imagine a delusional old woman screaming
and crying at an unseen presence in the middle
of the hall one night would have scared some
of the hotel guests and staff.
The fact that she was removed from the room
tells me that she may have even gotten violent
towards one of the other guests.
If me simply walking by was enough to trigger
delusions of the past, imagine what danger
someone trying to calm her down might have
been in.
That’s it for this episode of True Fear,
but you won’t want to miss out on the next
one, where I’ll be telling you about the
gunman on my subway train.
This is going to be the most intense episode
yet, and I actually have some pretty scary
raw footage of what went on that day.
So if you don’t want to miss it be sure
to subscribe to CZsWorld.
We’ve got new horrors every other week so
ring that death bell for notifications and
I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming, we both survive.